these are called friedman numbers it can
be written in a non-trivial way just
using the digits
itself together with any combination of
your usual
uh mathematical signatures plus minus
times divide you can even raise things
to a power and you can use some
combination of brackets if necessary so
25 is a friedman number okay why is 25 a
friedman number because it can be
written in terms of the two digits that
make it up as five
to the power two so i've just used the
raising power operator
to do that 121
same sort of idea two ones form eleven
and i raise it to the power 2 and i've
got 121. immediately i'm saying this is
could be described as recreational
mathematics i i it's the kind of thing i
used to
have great fun playing with but actually
there's some really neat things you can
do with it the brackets you've got to be
a little bit careful with you you're not
allowed just to simply wrap one number
up in a bracket so 125
is 5 to the power of 2 plus 1 so i'm
just using the brackets there to add the
2 and the 1 and make up 3 so 5 cubed is
125. well if i wanted to go for 1 say
with 4 digits then
9 2 6 1
is 21 to the power of 9 minus 6. so
there's actually 72 of these numbers
with four os uh digits and there's a
there's a really nice sort of subset of
them
14 of these are known as
nice
friedman numbers well a nice freedom
number is where the order of the digits
remains the same so um a simple one is
127.
127 is made up of minus 1
plus 2 to the power 7. the order of the
digits 1 2 7 is the same as appears in
the on the right hand side whereas if i
say took
125
the left hand side is 1 2 5 but the
right hand side is five two one or five
one two is that not nice
not formally nice it's uh for many of us
we quite enjoy 125 it's got many nice
properties but uh on this occasion it's
not a nice number not a nice friedman
number anyway so you could do i mean if
i want to just get a bit bigger it's 343
for example is just made up of
3 plus 4 to the power 3
or i could get a bit bigger and 6 4 5 5
is made up of 6 to the power 4 minus 5
all times 5.
so you get the idea that there are
you can make up various combinations and
in fact we've already come across a
class of these vampire numbers that
we've done uh videos with so vampire
numbers are made up of these where you
instead of using all the various
combinations we're just using the
multiplications so so vampire numbers
are an example so one two six zero is a
vampire number but it's also a friedman
number because it's 21
times 60. you know you can get a bit
bigger so the
we've got five digit numbers of which
there are 272 of them by the way 101
9 2 which is 101 to the power 2 minus 9
and if i went to a 10 digit 1 8 3 2
6 1 9 7 5 0 4 what's that equal to 91
248 to the power of five minus three
plus
naught times sixty-seven
the naught times sixty-seven together
have they just used the naught there to
cheat away well the notes in here
all right and so it's part of it but
what you it does it does make it there
is a um an interesting uh caveat which
we have to i should have mentioned and
you can't have
leading zeros they're not allowed for
example something like zero zero one
seven two nine and write that as one
seven zero zero plus twenty nine i'm not
allowed to have the leading zeros in
there in that definition but there are
some neat ones there's some even more
better than this even oh it gets better
what's the smallest number
that i can the smallest friedman number
that i can make up we're just repeating
the same digits these are called rep
digits rep digits rep digits okay and
the smallest is one two three these are
all nines one two three four five six
seven eight
one two three four five six seven eight
and it's made up of 9 plus
9 over 9 to the power of 9 minus 9 over
9 minus 9 over 9.
how about ones
so
now we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 and that is equal if i've
got my algebra right
11 minus 1 to the power of 11 minus 1
times 1 divided by
11 minus 1 minus 1.
so they've got the same number on the
right hand side
why are you laughing because it's just
cool
but i haven't finished there's more
there's more how about if i ask the
following
what there's there's a set of numbers
called your pan digital
we have covered pen digital numbers oh
you've done yeah okay well there's but
you haven't done pan digital friedman
numbers i bet here's one right so
appendage number is the one that
includes all the numbers in in any given
base
so if i say one two three four five six
seven eight nine well i can write that
as a friedman number because that's
equal to i think i need two brackets 86
plus two times seven to the power five
minus 91 all divided by 3 to the power
4. so that's one pan digital number we
can do another one nine eight seven
six five four
three two one right and this is eight
times 97 plus six over two to the power
five plus one again divided by three to
power four so you might say is it easy
to get a nice
digital number and indeed
they're there but they they're not that
easy to get there is one here two
six eight
four three
five one seven nine
and that is equal to remember the the
what's nice about it is the order
remains the same the order of the
numbers remains the same so it's minus
268 plus 4 to the power of 3 times 5
minus 1 to the power 7 minus 9 and that
will give you back your original number
it turns out as a number of digits and
the number increases
the likelihood of it being a friedman
number also increases if there are f of
n friedman numbers less than any given
number n then it turns out and i don't
know the proof of this i've been through
it that as n increases the ratio of f of
n over n tends to one in other words the
likelihood of finding a number tends to
unit so given a distribution of numbers
you know
of large n
then you pick a number at random then
the likelihood is that it's it's
actually a friedman number so the so the
higher we go in the number line the more
dense it becomes
a number yeah i think that's right
numberphile is supported by the
mathematical sciences research institute
but while we show you these friedman
numbers in roman numerals we'd also like
to thank these viewers who support us on
patreon and if you'd like to get
involved and maybe even adopt a number
on our website just for the fun of it
details are in the video description